getting the nation's all but stopped
economy working again is high on
president Trump's list mr. Trump
describes the effort as quote the
biggest decision he's ever had to make
the president has signaled interest in
May first as a possible day to start
easing restrictions
he says he'll let the facts determine
what he does
Nikole Killion is at the White House
this morning with more Nicole good
morning
good morning to you Dana President Trump
said he plans to name a new task force
Tuesday to examine when and how to
reopen the country and he said it's a
decision he won't make lightly I call it
the opening our country task force or
opening our country councils President
Trump said he's assembling a panel of
experts including doctors business
leaders and governors to help guide his
decision on when to restart the economy
I'm gonna have to make a decision and I
only hope to god that it's the right
decision but I would say without
question it's the biggest decision I've
ever had to make after the Surgeon
General warned this week could be the
nation's equivalent of Pearl Harbor or
9/11 the president said the u.s. death
toll could be substantially lower than
original estimates of 100,000 or more
it's really about the encouraging signs
that we see but as encouraging as they
are we have not reached the peak the New
York Times obtained projections from the
department's of Homeland Security and
Health and Human Services that showcases
could spike if stay at home orders are
lifted after 30 days officials with both
agencies declined to comment on the
document to CBS News don't let anyone
get any false ideas that when we decide
at a proper time when we're going to be
relaxing some of the restrictions
there's no doubt you're gonna see cases
as millions of unemployed workers hang
in the balance
the IRS announced automatic stimulus
payments will start going out next week
many small business owners anxiously
awaited loans from the payment
protection program to cover payroll CBS
News obtained this notice from Wells
Fargo warning of possible delays due to
hide
and and limited funds that could run out
so the money is getting out the
applications are far beyond what we ever
anticipated
Treasury Secretary has requested more
money for the loan program and has
restarted talks with congressional
leaders the president also said there
would be a meeting with Airlines over
the weekend they're eligible for 25
billion dollars in cash grants but
multiple sources tell CBS News that
Treasury told them they may have to pay
some of it back Michelle Thank You
Nicole
Nikole Killion at the White House